hey what's up guys mkbhd here i'm back
and this is the sony nex vg20 let's take
a look
if i had to describe this camera in just
a few words it would be the one that
breaks all the rules think of it as a
high-end dslr and a high-end camcorder
put together in one basically it's a
high-end dslr sensor from sony in a
camcorder's body but with a dslr mount
that has interchangeable dslr like
lenses that are adapted for camcorder
like video it's a crazy combination and
i totally love it this particular lens
here is one of my favorites from sony
it's the 18 to 200 millimeter zoom lens
that shoots at f 3.5 at its widest focal
length and it has a focus ring and a
zoom ring just like a regular dslr lens
so check it out it gets pretty massive
at 200 millimeters but the autofocus
here is present and it's incredible but
we'll get to that in a second either way
up top is a very impressive microphone
usually the built-in camcorder
microphones are just terrible but this
one goes above and beyond anything
you'll find on other camcorders it
records in dolby 5.1 channel surround
sound and it does a great job at it too
the rest of the hardware is pretty
self-explanatory on the back you have
your on off switch and your record
button and the battery and up top is an
alternative pinky record button and a
photo button to take 16 megapixel stills
yes
16 megapixel good looking still photos
that i mean that's just due to the
awesome dslr sensor at work that's
absolutely awesome for a camcorder
battery life with the stock 2016
milliamp hour battery was decent i got
around two hours of record time with it
and just overall build quality was rock
solid and you'd expect that from a
camera this price you have your
headphone jack for monitoring audio here
usb io hdmi the whole works it's really
nice and also the material that the
outside shell is made of is pretty
awesome too and you can't forget that
flip out three inch touchscreen lcd
screen it has a pretty basic menu system
and a single sd card slot next to the
manual controls would have liked to see
two here or maybe a cf card but i guess
one sd card slot is fine but when it
comes down to it you buy a camera for
the video quality and like i said at the
beginning this camera is ridiculous it's
a boss it breaks all the rules it has
sharp autofocus and dslr depth of field
it blew my mind it just doesn't make any
sense now there are also adapters that
let you use this with canon and nikon
lenses and other sony alpha lenses but
i'm just going to show you guys the
footage i took with this stock 18 to 200
millimeter lens
so this is the canon t2i that i'm using
to record this right now and it's a crop
sensor body at an equivalent of 48
millimeters that's the focal length so
without any further ado let's go ahead
and switch to the vg20 indoors you don't
really get a whole great sense of how
capable this camera is if i hold
something up to the camera you can see
the focus the main point of focus is
that it's pretty
average but it's very very tack sharp so
it's not fast but it's really really
sharp but indoor footage like i said
doesn't really take the most advantage
of this camera so we're going to do is
show you what it's capable of outdoors
and just note as you're watching this
footage that this is all auto focusing
on its own that's the beauty of this
camera has a large sensor from a dslr
combined with the focus of a regular
camcorder and it's basically like having
autofocus for video on a 5d mark iii
it's absurd so without any further ado
let's go ahead and take a look at that
check this out guys this is beautifully
sharp video outdoors everything in focus
is really really sharp and it's not even
sunny and even more beautiful is this
super soft bokeh you get in the
background you don't get that softness
in the background from a regular
camcorder you just don't get that now
that is the dslr sensor really working
now i know what you're thinking wow
mkbhd this is just general typical
footage from a random object did you
actually use this camera well yes if
you're following me on twitter at the
link in the description right below the
like button on this video you'll know
that i have footage from an entire
weekend of shooting outdoors in
wisconsin enjoy
[Music]
me
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
your face your face
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
score is now 2-1 stevens
so overall i clearly love this camera uh
and you can give a thumbs up on this
video if you like it too
otherwise the microphone is really
impressive the handle is really
convenient the eyepiece is really
adjustable the lcd the touch screen is
awesome i really really like this camera
uh and there hasn't been anything to
stop me from buying one
so uh yeah just
note that i really really like it and
you may too either way thanks for
watching this video guys i hope it was
enjoyable to you guys if you want to
check out the audio that i use the links
to that in their description and there's
a link to check out the vg20 in the
description i'm gonna put this down and
uh i'll go ahead and sign off now talk
to you guys later
peace
[Music]
back to mason
here he goes
oh
oh john to john lee great snack so good
job
this is